[Music]
in pedo radio news radio submitted by
seeing a song now out of all the song
choices what [ __ ] party this fella 30
that wasn't expecting it to be we came
out this is we give her time to thank
good good at Dolly's committed right
away a radio station is being
investigated after listeners heard a
disturbing piercing a piece of what is
this a piece of all six place in Tucson
Arizona in that area so there's this man
named Paul he apparently for the past
two years had this PSA in the middle of
the night on this oldies country station
that he owns called craved 97.7 SN what
he's saying more or less is something
like this
in many cases the penalty for possession
of pictures is worse than the penalty
for murder
you should understand that your internet
provider could report you to the police
if they catch you looking at a website
featuring naked juveniles if you have
such material you can save yourself
yourselves and your family a ton of
grief and save the taxpayers a lot of
money by never storing such pictures on
the hard drive of your computer always
use an external drive and write it where
nobody will ever find it likewise never
keep paper pictures tapes or films of
naked juveniles where anybody else can
find them what the [ __ ] why would you do
it eh I just come out and just said how
I have kiddie porn on my hard drive yeah
everyone else do the same you and I cool
it went a whole different direction I
thought it was just going to say if you
do have them you must delete them now
because you can face some big penalties
teaching them external hard drive burn
all paper copies he defends his PSA and
it's crazy that I went by for two years
and no one really picked up on it until
recent because all these people that are
listening to the station probably all
watch it together or respond
such a small station WC you said it's
late night to race so people might be
just driving and I Drive in paying
attention so they're assuming it's going
to be a good message on how to tell them
Adelita get imagine you're on a road
trip you just listening to country music
and you're just like our ticket they're
right here they're bigger and then
they're like if you have if you have
kiddie porn make sure you put it on an
external hard drive and it's like what
Sparkle members of this community they
all created a change.org petition
calling for the Federal Communications
Commission to revoke his radio license
over this heinous broadcast and so he
has now pulled his PSA from the airwaves
altogether because some of his
advertisers have received threats to
know they're pulling out of like from
advertising on his radio station but
he's still not backing away from the PSA
he still defends it because he says that
Arizona's penalties for possession of
child pornography is far too harsh oh
come on [ __ ] you what it means is far
too harsh what do they do [ __ ]
castrate you holy [ __ ] they're claiming
that sex exploitation of a minor is a
class 2 felony in Arizona and it carries
a minimum sentence of 10 years per
violation awesome like you could get
life in prison pretty much awesome
that's not long enough is he like not he
doesn't have common sense that by
fighting for it he's just revealing to
everyone that easy yeah he's a pedophile
hey if I'm gonna get competition I only
want to do a year in prison so like a
jackoff again after a year that's what
you try to say guys crazy why are they
investigating him like I'd be like Ram
man checking his house I'd investigate
him into Tommy's yeah everybody he said
my feeling is that these people don't
deserve life in prison just because they
have pictures of naked juveniles like no
picture is worth your life in prison
like no pictures like that bad enough I
could kind of see his angle though
because to me I think it's less of a
criminal act and more psychological I
think people need help so I kind of if
that is his angle we're like hey let's
get these guys outside of prison where
people are like burning houses and like
stealing cars
and put them in like a like a mental
institution I can see that Anil yeah but
that's not his example is like hey you
guys have it make sure you hide it so
you don't get caught exactly the
opposite is that he takes a solution
oh yeah the cameras right there he's
saying stuff without a solution you know
it means so like if you if in fact he's
going to say that this is obviously an
exactly this like Bart said seen you
throw up a solution he's like dude like
just hide that [ __ ] bro
like I could already picture him like
right now there's just like this
overweight white man with the white
mustache looking like Santa Claus yeah
with the cowboy hat and then he just
feels like looks like she's 12 mater so
I'm saying goodbye if you fits that
profile is they're afraid of these news
outlets I've been reporting it they
don't have a photo cane and I tried
googling if I get killed
yeah I wish they had a photo I don't
understand pedophile he was simply
providing his audience with facts that
the information is perfectly accurate
and important to true pedophiles
he claims that there is no connection
between the people who actually create
and distribute child pornography and
those who possess it so he's saying like
the people that are possessing it are
the real victims because their hats
spending the rest of their lives just
for having a couple of pictures I'm a
connoisseur I do not make them
I only enjoy what you think the
difference is in one case you're
molesting children and abusing them
causing children to do things that are
not natural for children to do and the
other case they're just possessing
pictures but see they are the people
that are facilitating exactly they're
creating the marketing I guess he's
thinking about it like drug users drug
abusers I mean drug sellers drug dealers
and drug users it's not my fault you
give me this good chopped tomography
that's very much would you say yeah you
don't like to talk about it way too good
I just can't have the National Center
for Missing and Exploited Children
their data suggests that at least a
hundred thousand children American
children are sexually exploited every
single year ow OH Chandra well I guess
we have 300 million human beings
visa contract study of the perpetrators
arrested for possessing child
pornography found that 40% had also been
accused of raping children Wow whoa
they're also saying that child victims
suffer at the hands of the offender who
sexually exploited them and the harm is
compounded when the offender
memorializes the victimization by taking
photos and videos and then distributing
these images on the Internet where
additional offenders use them - for the
purpose of sexual gratification why
can't I be a crime fighter that kills
people
I think this radio guy should get jumped
so what a fear hunter the sheriff is
investigating whether or not this PSA
violates any state law because there is
one of the county attorney is saying
even though he's completely against this
he is saying that this PSA is protected
speech under the First Amendment
there are serial rapists out there that
will rape everything in anything right
so I'm going to give them a chance to
redeem what they do for society by
bringing them on my team and we're going
to catch sexual predators and they're
going to rape back so my idea is to
support Joe's crime fighting idea so
this baby it could be your arm like
you're with baby weight yeah football I
like that idea - it'll be your bait
right so well we'll take them - martial
art schools will take them to you know
weapon training schools all this [ __ ]
will dress them super cute and then
we'll get children stripper school so
they not to seduce them oh yeah yeah
yeah basically it's like hit girl from
kick ass yeah but uh so they'll bring
them in and then you finish the job I
want the kid to finish the job well I'm
kind of lazy now I just want to see the
kid do the work come on I started off
strong it's disappointing all right I
want that little kid well it's not going
to be a little kid to be honest with you
it's just going to be a 25 year old like
Japanese the size of a six-year-old in
the US okay cool then I warn you this I
won't use bigger okay we'll go with that
one what about my baby
I was about sorry alive beautiful I feel
like I don't know if this is fact or not
but I feel like a lot of pedophiles they
can't control themselves and they know
they have a problem so I think on the
FBI site they should have a animated
child pornography section so now you
don't harm any kids but then if a
pedophile can get off on something that
may be a little reduced like their
sexual driver their anxiety levels so we
can jack off to the children porno
animation so you don't think it's kind
of like on animation we have animation
so no one gets hurt it's all fake you
also mentioned that it's a psychological
issue I think that doesn't help that I
think it just creates a bigger problem
for it and allows them to facilitate it
in a way that is accessible and makes it
okay so I see that people that get
arrested and they're always ashamed of
themselves
so it's like Oh which I wasn't like this
now you feel bad for my manicotti to
control this [ __ ] because I don't think
people wake up and say I'm gonna [ __ ] a
camel today oh yeah they know they're
doing percent wrong so I'm like if they
can just get their fix real it's kind of
like you know when people and they're
like trying to get off heroin there's
like those intermediate drugs or even
people like the cigarettes like they
have like NicoDerm CQ whatever I feel
like it's just it helps get rid of it
and they know it's bad but I think
slowly can transition it is that maybe
the animation gets older and older and
older and then finally goes to like a
real porn or someone their age and then
the kuya rehabilitated and they're not
kind of [ __ ] a tease anymore every
cool it don't work like that I think it
is like an actual psychosis they're like
when they literally no matter what it is
like they're always just going to think
of kids so if they always say it and
there was going to be like even if they
watching the animation anyway like I
actually don't know that feels like in
real life
shock therapy dude there will you just
take them to a senior community yeah
just put them in an only person time yep
they can't leave all you got that's
their worst nightmare just like no oh
come on aqui papi think I can do this
there so
oh what a good movie premise dude
everyone over 40 Paul hey what's up guys
thanks for watching we are going to
regularly start posting content on the
JK films Instagram so make sure you
follow us there a lot videos click over
here
[Music]
[Music]